hello
how's it going be careful with that
thing there's no way you can actually
drink a full drink of alcohol this thing
is like actually much
larger like it looks small because it's
it's actually like four feet
unfortunately it's gigantic correct it's
a modoc tiki mug i was like i ordered it
because i was like that's cool
it came in a box like this big and i was
like i can never use this
yeah it's it's become a uh pens in it or
something
exactly yeah um so yeah i as you can
tell i'm i'm
i know there's like dozens of us out
there but i'm just a huge modoc fan
like i was just a fan of this character
i feel yeah so
of course i i dove into the to head
games your comic and i
i was just reading the sort of finale
coda you guys were at the end
there was a very interesting line you
said i i feel like modoc
is a lot like batman and uh i would kind
of just like you
to the audience to explain what you
meant by that because it's not something
that really uh makes a lot of sense on
the surface but it really does
like once you think about it it does
once you watch this show you're like oh
i get exactly what it means
yeah i don't think anyone's uttered that
sentence before but
but what we're talking about is is um
that
there are certain characters that are
incredibly flexible i think
in in how they're adapted and i think we
think about batman
you have the adam west version you have
the christopher nolan movies the frank
miller stuff you have the saturday
morning
brave the bold you know for kids and
none of those versions are wrong
you know like it's a character that if
you get the core
essence right they can be in a kid's
cartoon they can be in an oscar movie
you know they can be in something that's
a lot more dark and adult and i think
modoc is that
because if you look at the character in
his his comic book history
you know there's times where he's a very
archvillain
uh you know who just wants to conquer
the world sometimes he's like a legit
menace and a monster and he's terrifying
other times he's used for comic relief
and
you know when we wrote head games we
wanted to do this
grant morrison kind of thing where you
you make sense of all of it it all
counts so you know in our mind when we
were doing
the series obviously we were going to do
an adult comedy and it was going to be
a little you know kind of more satirical
and jokey um
but we wanted to make sure that we did
that modoc felt like moda that he didn't
betray the essence of the character
and i think you know he's just as valid
as the the
one in the video game who i just played
you know who's a lot more of that
scarier menace
um and i think that's what's so fun
about
these comic characters and why they've
lasted this long
is that like lego batman and you know
christian bale batman
work one is not better than the other or
the right
version and i think modoc works that way
as well
i feel like the more important question
is who do you think would win in a fight
between batman and modoc
i think bodak would exhaust batman that
would pull it out
exactly intellectually yeah it would
just be a thing where like he's pulling
things out of his hover chair and
batman's pulling things out of his
utility belt would just be this big
pile of weapons piling up and then
batman would outsmart
him or he would realize like oh his
weakness is ego that's easy i can take
him down
amazing we should abs that's when the
crossover eventually happens it started
here on this interview
well i will cross over with harley quinn
i know patrick so maybe there you go
perfect sure it's super easy between
corporates okay and now that's
that's basically a contract we just did
uh i do think it's interesting though
because this show you know it kind of
you mentioned it a little bit in the
comics about how you know they're
humanizing him and the show does a great
job of like you know like
i want to make sure that people know
it's an extremely funny show but there's
like some shockingly
moving parts of this show and you see
modoc show up in 1967
you know and it's just this grotesque
character that's endured and it's like
what is it to you that was like i want
to dive into this character's sort of
emotions because he's kind of built he's
introduced is like
this robot monster thing like what to
you is like why did it endure and like
why did you specifically think i want to
dive into this thing's head
well i think it's that that marvel
recipe right it's like that jack kirby
stan lee thing where
you create this character who is larger
than life this big villain this floating
head with
baby arms and legs who wants to mind
blast you and
you've humanized them over the course of
of their appearances where
you know modoc has this flaw where he
wants to be
seen as an a-lister and he's conscious
of it and drives him crazy and i think
that's like
that being built into the character is
so cool and fun and it's
how he loses even very early on in his
appearances this is
his own hubris and um you know
uh being uh super driven and super
insecure i find incredibly relatable
and i was like i can i can build a show
out of that and
um you know asking these questions uh
that kind of led to the comedy of like
where does this guy go at night
you know he has to leave that captain
america panel where does he go does he
go home
is there a family waiting for him you
know and
he runs in he runs his evil
organizational what does that take
you know to keep that thing afloat and
the corporate the corporate structure i
really enjoyed like
learning the corporate structure of this
like super bowl like it just so it has
this office quality to it but it's it's
obviously heightened
even more which i was definitely pulling
pulling from that stuff so
that to me was so so funny and so real
and i think
i love that challenge like what you're
saying if you go in you're like well
here's a big marvel
monster can i get you to care and invest
in him and put him on this journey that
you see yourself in or you can relate to
and i think
that is my favorite part about the show
and hopefully it is very funny
we tried very hard i want to make sure
people know you know they don't go into
mohawk and you're like wow this is
a downer yeah it's a joke-heavy show for
sure but we want we didn't want to
undercut
the the drama but i think that's
something having worked in animation for
a long time
sometimes there's this sense of like oh
you can have an emotional scene but you
gotta have a joke right after and then
it's all wrapped up and then
we move on to the next story we wanted
this to be about people messy people who
um change and grow over a season so we
tried to really
make them feel real while still making
them be absurd and hilarious
i love a show that where it just sort of
feels like
no idea was like shot down like it just
kind of feels like
everything that was thrown out was like
yes absolutely so i'm wondering anytime
i see a show like that i'm like what was
an idea where you were like we
that can't we can't do that or like or
like something that even the
the higher-ups were like i don't know if
we're comfortable doing that with our
characters was there anything like that
in the making of the show
no i think they kind of embraced the
insanity of it i think you know there
was a few like
characters who it was it's funny they
weren't a-list they were like
d-listers who for rights issues we
couldn't use like stilt-man or pace pot
peter turner to century
we're like the only three we were told
no everyone else was like on the table
which is a very elite three like you
think
i still want to get my hands on turner's
country but um
you know they were they knew we were
respecting i think the toys
or you know the characters that we love
them and we understand these things mean
a lot to a lot of people like
there's someone out there who's the
biggest vanguard the screamer fan and we
can't do him wrong
and we have to honor that and and so
you know they trust us with the marvel
of it all but then also
you know i think we i said i
[ __ ] against the the ending a little
bit because it
wasn't going to end that way originally
it was going to be a little more of a
happier ending
and it scared me and we talked it
through and i think like
i always say like if something scares
you in a writer's room like run towards
it because it means it's probably a good
idea
uh because you're having a real visceral
reaction to it and um
and i felt like that part was
interesting to me because we we
create a show where there's a super
villain but you're gonna invest in him
you're gonna like him
he's gonna become the hero of the show
but he's a super villain and we need to
remind you of that so that part was
one where we didn't get pushback from
the studio or the network but
we i had pushed back like do i want to
go here with this character and i think
in the end it was the best way to
to wrap up his story for the season but
no there was
there was really nothing that we
couldn't do and we were encouraged to go
crazy i mean like there's stories we
didn't get around to telling and some of
them we put into the comic like that
whole super villain
um trade show was something i wanted to
do in the show we just never got around
to it i was like
actually be a fun little team up with
iron man in the comments
uh this show was it was announced in
2019 i think i think i remember
if i'm recalling quickly and it was
announced in a very different
environment
it was supposed to be the different
premieres different studio and i'm
wondering if in the interim it had to
change just for
logistic reasons just because i think it
was supposed to lead to a crossover if
i'm not
mistaken and i'm wondering if there's
anything in the in between where you're
like okay we have to take that out
because it doesn't work or did the show
sort of work as a standalone already
no it worked it was you know uh when
there was a plan for them to all cross
over
um marvel had talked to me about
possibly
doing that show for them so i ended up
consulting on some of the other shows
and you know the idea was though
everyone tell their story the way they
want to tell it do not
work towards this crossover like we all
had
very specific stories for our season so
there wasn't a single thing in modoc
that was supposed to lead into anything
in fact
i clearly wrote myself into a giant
corner by the ending of
of season one that i would have had to
figure out you know how to do that
but um no you know and then when we
changed
kind of studios they were like this is
working just keep going do your thing
like you know uh we're happy with what
this is and and like we're
we encourage you to just like keep keep
going so that's what we did
is there anything you can tell me about
what the offenders would have looked
like
it was was there like story on the table
already or was that sort of like you
said you weren't
working towards a crossover so was it
sort of we'll get to it when we get to
it or was there a conversation
what that would have looked like well
they all the shows had a
very different aesthetic and style
to them so and you'll see like hip
monkey looks nothing like
modoc and it looks so cool um but
uh no it was kind of like i had
an idea you know uh i kind of pitched
them a german idea of
what how they could all come together
who the villain would be why this would
make sense the adventure they could kind
of go on but
that was it it was real early early
talks and and
you know um friends with the guys who
were running
hit monkeys so they put in a few like
little easter egg things but we never
really
um went out of our way to to kind of set
anything up or figure out how it would
work i think that was kind of the fun of
it
i'm kind of obsessed with like the
logistics of stop motion because it's
just it seems like
the hardest thing in the entire world
and i'm wondering just
what was sort of the most innocuous
thing that someone wouldn't notice in
the show that took
the most time to get right you have to
think of it like live action and modoc
is such an insane
character and design and he's you know
like just getting his chair to work
and and do what we needed it to do to be
this
this swiss army knife and and function
or like you know his arms he can't clap
you know but you write it into a script
no not class but like the way he's built
his arms don't touch so he had to like
create little close-up
you know hands and stuff and um uh you
know how does he fit into a car look at
him so we had to build
things because we have scenes in in cars
and stuff um
you know it was it was more like
practically how do these people inhabit
a world
um but you know stop motion is such a
very specific art form and it's
it's incredible and um you know watching
the craftsmanship that goes into it was
unbelievable and for me i'd come from 2d
so i had to kind of re-learn how to how
to use
to look to do this sort of animation how
do you edit this how do you
write towards this how do you get the
most out of it and um
it was it was a blast to be thrown into
the deep end and
working with with alex kamer and eric
towner who are the
directors on the show and and they
really
took me through the process so i could
understand it and you know you can even
see like you know i think
uh i'm very happy with how the pilot
came out but i learned how to edit
stop motion better as the show
progressed so i think even the cuts are
a little tighter and better and
there's more tricks you learn you know
so um
it was all it was all learning
experience in a really fun way because
you know i was on american dad for years
and you get comfortable and it's really
good to you know change it up and try
something new
absolutely um so i i don't know if you
could
tell me if there's a season like season
two is sort of i mean i don't think it's
been officially
announced i don't know uh we're we're
waiting to hear
and uh i would say if you're very
nervous about the fate of medoc's family
let hulu know
how much do you have planned for season
two if if right now they're like okay
modoc season two it's happening could
you leap right into production or is it
like oh it's
happening we gotta come up with a show
yeah no we absolutely have a shape
for what we wanna do and there's things
we set up in um
you know season one like hexis and stuff
that we want to come back to
and and address and obviously we have to
immediately address what happens in the
finale
um but um yeah no there's there's a lot
of cool stories
you know that we want to want to tell
and and we know
we've purposely left things in a certain
way with certain characters and
relationships that we want to see
uh we want to take uh with us so um yeah
there's a lot of plans in place
and and we we had some big conversations
about it kind of towards the end and
have talked to hulu about it too uh as
well and they're
really excited to know where we want to
take the show and stuff so
uh i'm hoping you know people watch it
and they want more
exactly uh something you mentioned
specifically on twitter was uh and it's
in something from the comics was
introducing uh melissa's girlfriend and
just because you sort of layer in the
fact that she's bisexual and it's just
like
wonderful little character detail that
that's just sort of in and i'm wondering
if that was to come to the show if if
that's something
that was important to you from the
beginning or is it something that
because again i i just think it's really
lovely the way it just sort of
is i love the idea that modoc is this
super villain
but having a bisexual daughter doesn't
phrase him
that's not a problem to him so i'm
wondering if that was something
conversations you had
for season one something you always plan
to reveal in season two or anything like
that
yeah it was something we always kept
trying to get to in season one the
problem is season one is so much about
modoc and everyone's relationship to
modoc that we never really get to see
melissa's life outside of um of him
and you know there was moments where we
tried to work it in like you know in the
pilot
uh she holds up a dead boyfriend and
we're like i don't want to like
introduce this relationship and then the
first thing we do is murder
the person you know and you know there
were lines and stuff
that were always in there so um i was
like i want to tell the story until
right and i was very annoyed that we
didn't get to it was just kind of
you're constantly cutting things for
time and you know and really
the her story with modoc was about them
you know and not her life outside of it
but it was always something that was
like
i wanted to get to that um because you
know representation is very important
for me
in in the show so we were so happy that
we were able to kind of
canonize it in the comic and um
and so was melissa fumer was so excited
i actually bought that
page for her and gave it to her so she
has that
that one um so uh yeah it's something
that was like
we absolutely want to do and the same
thing with lou like we really didn't get
to see his life
you know too much outside of modok jody
we only got that kind of
one episode with her and you know wonder
man where
i i would love to just be able to now
you know
not leave mark behind but introduce
these characters that you
love them that you're you want to go on
journeys with them into their own worlds
as well
outside of how they relate to modak so
that was something that we absolutely
want to tackle
in season two uh with should the family
survive
um yeah but uh yeah yeah
it's it's a it's a big thing for me i
think you know representation was also
built into
the family itself is we wanted to to
showcase a modern
family that feels real you know and i'm
in an interfaith
relationship or marriage and that leads
to a lot of interesting stories and the
same thing of
having um you know a mixed family where
modoc is jewish and uh you know um
uh jody is mexican and having uh
a son having a bar mitzvah being able to
tell my story you know that was just
something we really wanted to do because
there are so many just all white you
know
animated families and the last thing we
wanted to do was kind of add
to that as opposed to be able to create
a family that feels new and
and different and unique and and kind of
representative of what
families look like now absolutely
besides the giant heads
yeah you know the core is there the
chorus yeah
yeah again thank you for taking the time
and just thank you for the show in
general because again i never thought i
would see a modok show
much less like i'm on a major stream if
i were so again this is a
this was a treat thank you thank you for
for
i love that a modoc fan enjoyed it that
means a lot to me